preparándose para llevar alivio a un
continente entero
estos son los camiones que pronto
distribuirán inyecciones desde la filial
the fighter en bélgica hacia todos los
rincones de la unión europea dentro de
esta fábrica millones de vacunas están
siendo producidas en masa luego de que
la unión europea tomara cartas en el
asunto
los primeros lotes de estaba con unas
eran despachados desde la fábrica de
facer aquí en bélgica en los próximos
días
washington stage
la vacuna también será producida en
otros lugares incluido este la sede
variante en mainz alemania 27 de
diciembre es la próxima fecha clave es
cuando algunos países incluidos francia
alemania austria e italia indicaron que
empezarían a vacunar a los trabajadores
en primera línea las contrapartes
europeas francia empezar a vacunar a
finales de la próxima semana los
próximos lunes ya habremos empezado a
vacunar será un comienzo gradual como se
podrán imaginar dimensiones en francia
los residentes de hogares de la tercera
edad están en el grupo de los primeros
que se vacunarán también se les unirán
los mayores de 75 años y aquellos
mayores de 65 años que tengan problemas
de salud esto justo antes de que la
vacuna esté disponible para el resto de
la población alemania ha puesto en
marcha una estrategia similar las
autoridades han convertido en lugares de
aglomeraciones como gimnasios y estadios
en centros de vacunación masiva también
le dará prioridad a los residentes que
viven en lugares de cuidado antes de
distribuir la vacuna al resto de la
población pero tomará tiempo antes de
que la vacuna sea
asequible para todos hasta entonces
despliegue de la vacuna será una prueba
a la habilidad del bloque de sobrepasar
uno de los retos logísticos más grandes
de su historia